[Musique]
eh bien on se réfère à l'assistance des
dictionnaires
donc c'est le 36 19 tu appelles le
numéro et il ya une dame qui te
certifier que le mot existe bien c'est
une super bonne question parce que ça
tire les 13 équipes qui courent mari
venu à mettre notre qu'imagine tuba je
ne vois que ça comme comme d hab alors
là ça va être une réponse tout à fait
logique c'est quand tu tires quand tu
fais ça avec ta bouche s'attire la peau
de l'oeil et dans ces cas là tu n'es pas
encombré par des petits bourrelets qui
peut y avoir en fait ça te tire la peau
pour bien attraper les cils donc en fait
c'est cette technique loisil t étant la
mère de tous les vices c'est ce qui m'a
toujours dit ma mère quand j'étais jeune
je sais rien du tout donc donc si c'est
pas bien mais en même temps j'ai envie
de te dire que oued et x 2,8 a envie
d'avoir rien n'a rien rien rien à faire
voilà d'être là en mode légumes mais
mais mais tu peux pas tu peux pas parce
que tu as tellement chose à faire que tu
vois là tu veux te genre qu'ils aient
pas de procrastination tu veux pas
remettre au lendemain
donc tu veux tu actives et tout secoué
il faut du courage pour réussir à dire
non non non aujourd'hui je reste posé
simplement du courage
non
[Musique]
c'est des questions de non par an en
fait parce que quand on est parent on
est plein de paradoxes
on dit tout et son contraire on dit un
truc le lundi un autre club mardi et en
fait être parent c'est s'adapter donc
c'est dire lundi et mais pourquoi tu ne
parles pas ma chérie il faut absolument
que tu me racontes qu'est-ce qu'il va
pas pourquoi ses états d'âme le mardi
donc voilà ça fait partie du job de
parole parce qu'en règle générale une
fois qu'on a un peu marché est un peu
parlé on marche beaucoup et on parle
trouve donc on fatigue et je ne dis pas
ça pour mon adolescence que j'aime
infiniment tutelle mme chirac
[Musique]